let's turn to my gun everybody hear me
that's good
that's not working okay hello everyone I
am thrilled to be here it is my first PI
data conference and immediately getting
the opportunity to talk about one of my
main interests which is machine learning
is you know really exciting as Jonathan
already mentioned my name is Florian I'm
the project lead of the ad targeting
team at Yelp and in the next 30 minutes
I'm gonna share the most important
pitfalls and lessons we've learned at
Yelp when working on the CTR prediction
system and my hope is that by doing so
this will allow you to run your own
machine learning applications with a
fewer surprises improved understanding
of model behavior and overall better
results and while I'm gonna use CTR
prediction is the running example
throughout the presentation I will
well the lessons that I'm gonna talk
about I think they they generally apply
to machine learning applications in
general Before we jump right into the
details still I want to briefly
introduce Yelp and also CTR prediction
first of all just by a quick show of
hands who in here knows about Yelp yes
almost everybody that's what I was
hoping for positive feedback is always
great so I'll keep it really brief
Yelp's mission is to connect people with
great local businesses that is really
what we're all about
and as you can see from these numbers
the so we have a lot of users we have a
lot of data so the first I can tells you
that we have more than 90 million
monthly unique users just on mobile we
have more than 100 million reviews in
our platform that we can work with and
probably most surprising to you we have
or Yelp is present across 32 countries
around the world so Yelp has a really
global
footprint at this time and that's
already everything I wanted to say about
Yelp specifically let's talk about CTR
prediction so first of all CTR
it stands for click-through rate and
since I'm going to use P CTR throughout
this presentation quite a lot of times
that simply is predicted click-through
rate and the question we're trying to
answer with CTR prediction is when we
want to show an ad what is the
probability that a user would click on
that ad so if you look at the example
over here is it 9 percent is it 5
percent is it 1 percent and the reason
we want to know that is because if you
think so if you think about it whether
user clicks not like this probability is
really a good proxy for relevance and we
definitely want to show relevant ads
because that's good for all in wolf
parties that's good for for the users
obviously it's good for the advertisers
and also for Yelp and as you've seen we
have a lot of data a lot of users so
Yelp is pretty big and more than 80
percent of the revenue that DL makes
comes from local advertising and CTR
prediction is really at the heart of
that local advertising system so in
essence CTR prediction is really
important for Yelp how do we do it we
use logistic regression with thousands
and thousands of features and and
millions of training data and also
testing data and now you might wonder
why is there a dog on this slide and the
answer to that is we named all of our
models after dog treats the curtain wall
is called kovash a Hungarian dog and
just for the fun of it
let's have a look at previous models so
we had French Brittany Icelandic sheep
dog and also the Korean Jindo already so
that's a great side effect of working at
the working in the at targeting team you
get to know more about doctors than you
ever thought you would ok let's jump
into lessons learned
yes you've seen the model we're using is
really I would say a large scale model
thousands of features and millions of
samples let's tell it down a little bit
though and think about how would an
architecture look like if it were just
to start out with CTR prediction and the
one that I was able to come up with is
this one so as you see it's split up
between the offline and the online world
and I'm gonna start out in the offline
world with the data which is where it
usually usually begins for machine
learning or machine learning entering
your data scientist and I'm just going
to assume that we have the data already
so once we have data we can train a
model on it and once we have that model
we can put it in some online production
environment maybe into a service or it
can make predictions and in the case of
CTR prediction we were very fortunate
that we get automatically labeled user
feedback for every advertisement that we
show because the user either clicks on
it or it doesn't click on it and now
when we if we log the input data to the
model and also the user feedback then
automatically automatically what we get
is basically all the data that we need
to train a new model and that really
completes so writing to the logs
completes the whole fight cycle and we
can train new models again with newer
data and and do that over and over again
and this is the basic architecture that
we're going to work with throughout the
presentation and I'm gonna step by step
point to point out some areas of where
we can improve the architecture and talk
more about that and those lessons that
I'm going to talk about can roughly be
grouped into infrastructure and also
model comprehension so let's start out
with infrastructure oh by the way
because it's dogs again the Corgi well
the mascot off the ads team is the core
game so you're gonna see a lot of quarry
slides okay
so this is our current architecture now
I was mentioning logs before
and the first thing that I want to point
out is that you should log at the source
of the online prediction and what I mean
by that is the place in your system
where you make the prediction you should
also log it if it's in a service you
should log that the input data in that
service and not somewhere downstream the
reason for that is that if it happens
downstream then a developer that that
works on on that part might not know
that it's important for floating-point
numbers to have a big amount of digits
of precision and not just rounded up to
two or one digits of precision
and there are all kinds of things that
can happen and once you change the
actual data that you're logging from the
one that you see online you have
corrupted successfully your offline
training data because your training that
is different from what you see in your
online world and that is exactly what
you don't want to happen so it might
seem like a minor detail but logging at
the source of the online prediction that
can save you a lot of hassle so we got
that into our architecture now still how
do you know even if you log the source
of the online prediction how do you know
that you're logging the right thing and
that's where prediction verification is
what we call it comes in what you do
there is you look at the logs that
you've written and you make a prediction
with the same model again offline and
you see whether a prediction you make
offline gives you the same result as the
one that you make online if it does then
you know okay it seems to be matching it
seems to be seems to be good there is
not a problem but if there's if it
doesn't match then you probably should
call in your engineers to look at it
more deeply you got that into our
architecture now the final point for the
the infrastructure lessons that I want
to make is is this one it's to make the
offline iterations as fast and scalable
as possible I think we all know that
machine learning
not a discipline where we have hard
rules to come from A to B it's very much
explorative you're trying out some
methods approaches and in the end you
evaluate it and then you see ok it's
working or it's not working and in other
words you have a lot of iterations that
you're going through and the faster and
more scalable iterations are the more
you can you know iterate and progress so
this is really key I think to having
fast results and one part that I want to
point out there is automation so if a
developer has to kick off every job that
is involved in the the offline
infrastructure like evaluation model
training everything then that takes
quite a while why not just automate
everything so you kick it off once the
whole pipeline runs and you get an email
of the evaluation in the end in your
inbox that's much more it's faster and
also automated visualizations I
personally think visualizations are
great but if they're just hanging out in
my Python notebook that some developer
you know code it up on a couple months
ago and only a couple developers know
about it and sometimes they use it but
not always it's not too helpful if it's
a useful visualization it should really
be included into your evaluation report
automatically so you see every single
time you do it and then I mean it can't
hurt you to look at some helpful
visualization so it's always in on your
mind basically and yeah do we add Yelp
do we add Yelp also well what is the
infrastructure at Yelp look like so this
is an overview of the offline training
infrastructure at Yelp and we start out
with merging the logs I can mention
before we have on the one hand the input
for the model prediction and on the
other hand the user feedback so we merge
that together then we sample down
because we're in a fortunate situation
where we actually have too much data
that we don't want to process all of it
and then the whole pipeline begin
first there is future engineering of
course you want to think about new
features implement them add them to the
model and then you kick off the pipeline
its feature extraction model training
and evaluation and in the end you get an
email that tells you either yeah you got
to start over again because it's not
good enough or it's good to go you can
push it to production and as you might
have noticed already from the background
image everything in here that you see
except for the feature engineering part
is really in the cloud we use Mr job in
combination with idea AWS EMR to run
every job which makes it very every job
in the cloud which makes it very
scalable and especially the model
training is well that's always it though
at the heart of machine learning
pipeline I would say and there we use
spark with a great success so far so the
the training of models is really on
there on the order of minutes for us
keep in mind that we have to do cross
validation and grid search so it takes a
little longer but on average one model
is on the order of minutes yeah that's
as much as I wanted to say about that so
these are the the lessons we've learned
so far long at the source of Yellin
prediction verify your predictions and
make offline iterations fast and
scalable now let's talk a little bit
about model comprehension and hopefully
we'll see more than this poor Corgi
again this is our current architecture
and there is one piece that is utterly
missing right now and I hope that many
of you have noticed already what I what
I mean and it is evaluation evolution is
super important when it comes to machine
learning and I'm not gonna talk about
you know the the standard stuff that
you're gonna do the cross-validation
having a holdout validation set or doing
a/b testing online what I want to talk
about instead is that you should focus
on a single metric
and to motivate that a little bit think
about a I system where I have two very
important metrics and you're always
looking at those two metrics to you know
figure out is it improvement or or not
and then you you make a change in your
model ends it improves one of the
metrics but the other one goes down so
what are you gonna do probably you're
gonna have a long discussion with your
fellow engineers and maybe make a
decision at the end but then as it so
happens the next time the one metric
goes down the other one goes up so
you're just just not gonna make a lot of
progress what instead you should do I
think is to figure out one metric that
works for you one that is really your
attack objective take your time to do
that and then focus only on a single
metric for making decisions you
shouldn't trust it blindly though you
should always you know have other
metrics in the background that you do a
safety check on but yeah focusing on
multiple metrics I think is a recipe for
disaster our metric that were using is
mean cross entropy which is the mean of
the negative log likelihood of the
logistic regression model and that is
really what we use for making decisions
on a day to day basis now again we have
alternative metrics as well like
calibration plots and and other things
that we look at but this is really yeah
the the big one I've talked about
visualizations a little bit before
already that I'm a big fan of
visualizations and I gotta say again and
again I'm amazed by how much information
you can convey with a good visualization
it happened a couple times already that
we just finished you know creating or
generating this visualization and then
we noticed immediately oh there is room
for improvement like we could split this
feature out into two or we could do a
piecewise linear instead of you know
just having a linear relationship it
makes it super obvious if there's
something wrong with your model and one
of the tools so we started to use and
generate more and more visualizations
just to understand what's going on and
one of the tools that were using
a lot for that is Zeppelin which allows
us to do very exploratory work in over
over a big amount of data and to give
you a few examples of the visualizations
the first one that you see is the
featured contributions in other words
which feature is really the most
important for your model which one
drives it the most and you can see that
the features are ranked on the on the
y-axis and each bar
you know indicates one feature and if
it's to the right then it's it's good
for the target variable in our case CTR
if it's to the left then it drives it
down and not only does it give you a
great overview of what's happening
inside your model it also tells you that
maybe there is this really really
important feature that that you have
that has also a lot of uncertainty in it
so maybe you want to focus on dialing
down that uncertainty a little bit and
and basically get your priorities
straight at a prior to it or do whatever
tool you have at your disposal and the
second visualization here is also very
useful it's the I would say the classic
feature plotted against the target value
the target variable CTR in our case
again and here for example you can see
the count is on a log scale so you can
see that the the very first bar it might
make sense to split that are into
another feature because it doesn't
really correspond with the overall trend
that we see with the Larian one that's
just one example
okay so that was evaluation and it sits
at the center of of the whole
architecture it's it's both both offline
and online because there's a be testing
as well which I mentioned so you
definitely want to do that now the next
topic that I want to talk about is
personally to me the most interesting
and it is thresholds now the thresholds
I don't mean just a normal threshold on
a feature or something what I mean by
thresholds is
putting a threshold on the prediction of
your model in our case that means
sometimes the the predicted CTR is
really low which which tells us that you
know the relevance of this ad wouldn't
be very high and in that case we'd
rather not show yet at all because
that's hopefully good to for the users
there's there's an opportunity cost to
show ads the the effect that this has
though is that automatically the online
world that we're seeing is different
from our offline training data just
because of the threshold because we
don't get those you know those
advertisements that are below the
threshold we don't get user feedback on
that so we don't have it in the training
data so let's see how that plays out
what you see here is for three models
you see the the CTR in one hand which is
the let's say we know the true CTR of an
advertisement and then the P CTR what
the model thinks it's it's gonna be so
the first model let's assume it's doing
a really good job around the threshold
the line is really the threshold here so
either it's above or below the threshold
so first of all let's assume it's doing
a really good job around the threshold
and you know sometimes it makes a little
mistake and it's very rare so we don't
see a lot of these impressions in our
training data then on the other hand
means that the second model that's based
on this training data doesn't know how
to behave around the threshold and makes
a lot of errors which is bad on one side
but on the other side it's good because
we're getting those impressions into our
training data again which lets our next
model be good
around the threshold again so it's it's
really this up and down this periodic up
and down that we really do not want to
happen all right we don't want to have
that so what can we do about it so one
idea is usually when you do well when
you do offline training you always have
some time frame over which you select
your training data and now if you do
more frequent retraining
then what you might want to end up with
is that you have the predictions from
multiple models that have been online in
your training data
now the first model was good the second
model was bad the third model was good
overall on average we get a you know a
good amount of bad advertisements into
our training data which then if you
train over all of that
let's our next model do a decent job
around the threshold so it basically
smoother that smooth is out that that
trend it's only a well it's only a fixed
though it doesn't really solve the
problem because they're still a little
bit of up and down but it might help you
to but not get interrupted by this
behavior with all the other stuff that
you're trying to measure and trying to
improve now a better way of tackling
this is to do a deliberate sampling of
bad ads that from time to time you see
okay this model would put this
advertisement below the threshold but
let's actually slip it through so that
we get a little bit more of exploration
in the area and we can then use that or
profit from that by having it in our
training data and being better at
exploitation with the next model and
ideally you want to do that in a smart
way so that you show as few bad as as
possible obviously that's the harder one
yeah but that's I think that the goal
that you should strive for now there is
one more point that I glossed over
before when talking about this behavior
and that is online when we have you know
a/b testing for example you have a
couple models online that we compare
against they're only what we see is
really this part of the data so in other
words if you look at model one we do not
see the strength of model one that it
has of ads that are below the thresholds
that it keeps below the threshold
because that's hidden to us
and we also do not see
the what's the same thing the strength
or weakness of models to keep
advertisements that would be above the
threshold also about the threshold for
the predictions if it pushes it below a
threshold we're not gonna see that
so our emulation will always be a little
bit biased now if you think about this
scenario where we have just normal a be
testing with the current model in green
which maybe gets 90% of the data of the
traffic and the new model which we hope
is going to do better gets it say 10%
then what we came up with to solve this
overall problem of you know not having
that data available around the
thresholds is to do Reece chorong
offline so all the impressions that the
current model would have seen all the
ads at the current models chord we would
score it offline with the new model as
well and that will tell us then it's the
model better for the the ones that let's
say the current model puts something
above the threshold it should be below
the threshold the new model knows that
it puts it below the threshold we would
get that into our evolution and
vice-versa for them adds that the new
model has seen online and then we take
all of that and do the evolution of of
the whole thing that's what we call
combined with scoring and so if the
traffic is 50/50 then that's an absolute
fair comparison between two models all
right that was model comprehension
so to recap evaluates evaluate evaluate
and be aware of those threshold effects
now there is one more aspect that I'd
like to talk about that you know I'm
gonna add to this whole architecture and
because it's so important to me or I
think in general that is it's got to be
right to center in simplicity so I
believe that simplicity should be the
main guideline or one of the main
guidelines for software engineers and
especially in the machine learning area
where the concepts that we're dealing
with are complex by nature already and
what I mean by simplicity so I think
that it's not not a bad idea or even a
good idea to start out with a rule-based
approach if you don't have anything else
what's what's wrong about it you get a
better understanding of your problem
domain and in the same way and it's with
simple models start with simple models I
know there's a big hype about deep
learning but if you start out with using
deep learning for the wrong kind of
problem you might not be so successful
and Occam's razor goes in the same
direction if you have two models that
perform about the same way choose the
simpler one I totally agree with that
now the next point is appropriate metric
I talked about that try to pick one
metric that really that really resonates
with your overall objective and that
will simplify our life and then there's
this topic of documentation pretty sure
that
yeah probably nobody in here likes to do
documentation but on the other hand it's
super important it is if you have some
machine learning related code and you
add documentation to it automatically it
makes it so much simpler just by adding
one or two lines of you know text and
there's this Tech Talk simple made easy
by rich Hickey who is the creator of
closure which i think is probably a best
tech dog that I've ever seen so if you
haven't watched it I can highly
recommend that all right so adding
simplicity and well-documented and that
completes our whole architecture and
again to recap the lessons above all
keep it simple and that's all from my
side thank you
so we're gonna open it up for any
questions that anybody has for Florian
and if we can just repeat the question
okay yeah
mmm so let me see so you're basically
going for for the better version here
did you deliberately sample or what is
the question exit yeah
yeah so the question is instead of
having a strict threshold below which we
don't show any ads have a small
probability that we're even even though
an ad is below that threshold we show it
and that's exactly what I was trying to
convey here with the better method where
even if the model thinks that it's below
the threshold you might want to sample
it and let it through and then in the
end show it to get some feedback so you
explore more and yeah ideally the
probability of that happening would be
bigger around the threshold like close
to the threshold and and really small if
it's you know close to probability of
close to P CTR of zero does that answer
the question yes great
any more questions yes please what is
the threshold it's it's a strict rule
where let's say the P if the predicted
click-through rate is above 1% where
we're going to show it if it's below 1%
we're not going to show it so it's a
strict rule that you add to do the whole
process you can choose the number that
you want I mean it's 5% 10% whatever
whatever fits your a problem yeah
there's one more question
combined restoring
so the question is to explain combined
restoring again I can absolutely
understand that it's not super clear
because it's quite involved topic so the
point is if we if you look at this and
we let's say those three models all of
all of these are online and we make
predictions online with these three
models and what we don't see
and like all the data that we have for
available for our evaluation algorithms
is only the green dots so if one model
is really good at keeping all the ads
that should be below the threshold also
keeping them below the thresholds we
don't see that at all in our data and
now with combined restoring if let's say
the current model is not as good at
doing that but the new model is really
good at keeping them below then the
current model will have some ads that it
you know makes the wrong prediction that
go above the threshold but the new model
will then say if we do the restoring of
that it will say okay it should have
been below the threshold and we do get
user feedback on on those on those ads
so we can really tell whether the new
model was better in that sense or not
all right any more questions
okay all right let's get flora in
another hand of